we're here with the official Green Arrow
character breakdown from injustice to
now this was taken from nether realms
live stream but the game launches just
two weeks from now on May 16th so be
sure to LIKE and subscribe to keep up
with all of our injustice to coverage
that's really easy to say well he's very
irritating the fight he was a great hit
and run character but I think one of his
major issues is he didn't really do a
lot of damage so that's something we
look to change in this game so for
example his hurricane beau is back but
now it has a meter burn and it'll
actually not be hone it up and he gets a
combo and so he's got more combo
potential drown does more damage ray
yeah you know you have to work a lot
harder a lot harder to get his damage
and he still retains some of his best
keep up moves he still has the savage
blast his arrows are still very very
quick and you can actually we'll wait
till we get to that right okay sorry
the other new wings like Steve did the
other new thing you'll notice is he no
longer has the blade on his bow so some
of his normal attacks of change is one
one one has a new animation new
properties and the big one is is back to
his back to used to be a really short
range overhead and now it's this long
range mid and it has three hits
now I would say that their reveal who
said like in the last one like this the
shock arrows yes maybe weren't as strong
in the good of it like so now they
actually have some new properties that
helps again get more damage on the table
right wait that's nice one money like
you can actually combo off them much
easier that's in two to three combo two
to three character power and you get
that see ya
and he still has the fire hose measure
very very fast and he still has the eye
syrup now the other thing about his
character power is when you held the
arrow in the original it was kind of
limited about what you could do so
there's a couple new things number one
you could dash forward and bat so while
he's holding it he has free mobility
because if you can jump you can do it
down to get duck and now he can - and
you can also put the arrow away
oh so let's say you have a nice air lab
and you're holding it you're thinking
about using it you decide not to you can
actually put it away and you'll see in
the yuan it's still available and the
next time you use an arrow it will be
the eye serum
how'd you pin why you hit the flip
stance button oh boy
left rude and he can you can do this
with any videos and then they'll be
ready for anytime you wants to use so
you could even shoot two fire arrows and
then put away and you still have your
one and then he also has a new arrow
type which is the meter brute arrow and
it's I'm so happy for this boxing-glove
era alone this makes me infinite happy
infinite happy and boxing low Boxing
Club arrow is basically the best arrow
it does a ton of damage it's super fast
and it's isn't that not so far back its
advantage on block it's it's basically
for a barred meter you you get the the
best arrow you could possibly get what's
can you put it and you can put it away
you can put it away
so you can just have that thing on deck
and you have it on deck and now you
could do a block string into it and be
advantage you could use it to
projectiles maybe maybe you're getting
zoned out
no one's gonna win a projectile train
against this not the boxing yea-ah
really cool and we also should show us
throw which is great and a super getting
a lot of tweets real quick I'm not
tweets that I'm twitch chat and reading
people wanting to see the DLC carriers
yeah well we don't have them Michelle we
don't have the Nisshin no that's I mean
like we always do these characters are
not done yet they think they're done no
there they are not on danske there we
are finishing this game and then DLC is
being worked on as we speak so we I will
say this occasion or Twitter and such
you will see all the DLC characters on
the stream right when we were able to
show them but they are not done yet no
let's get the game of can the game out
the door then we'll talk about that so
basically green arrow retains most of
what made him a good character in the
original but now he'll have better
reward when he actually gets a hit going
and even more better mobility options
when he has a zero and bigger damaging
combos and boxing-glove Peter Pan and
boxy glove arrow so let's go through
some of his abilities absolutely switch
them both like you always do to think he
said it as a good thing yeah all right
so for this loadout we went with the
really cool gear yeah I haven't seen
that before trying to cap attack this is
what I would call tactical green arrow
when he's on military s Commission's I
have Laura for every one of my load yes
yes a military s commissions yes a
military vision well he's a superhero
not a soldier
so he goes on military I'll guarantee it
okay I argue with more though so this
ability I have replaces boxing love
arrow with bola arrow and that will tide
you ponent up and then he gets a pre
comp can you put it away you can put it
away so wait a minute so the ground
effects chest change my bad yeah look at
this color huh huh clever yeah that's
cool so this gives them even more combo
potential there's potential with resets
you could do the bola arrow and then
just gain hit advantage to restain them
saying an advantage meaning meaning how
much time green arrow has before the
opponent can move so like when you did
up he's in what's called hit stun where
you can see dark sides he's stumbling
back and green arrow can move before
great regen can we get onto the can we
got camera real quick Matt Burke sleek
and see that that darkside repression
again ah ah that is hit stun yeah that's
how we explain it that how he hits done
nice um were there any other returning
moves that you wanted to talk about
because I think you only hit like the
bullet spin and um he has uh very less
right he's got that he has stingers back
and you can still meet her burn it it's
a great wake up attack good low overhead
yeah it's a good low overhead it leaves
him advantageous a lot okay and as this
bubbly the arrow here you
take some two slots right correct
because this one is so powerful and has
so much potential
it takes up two slots so you're giving
up your boxing bávaro and you're giving
up a chance another ability for a really
really really powerful ability yeah
that's pretty awesome yeah so then let's
look at another load app for about three
and for this one I went with kind of a
high mobility arrow load app so one is
space control he has Skybolt
where he actually shoots a bolt up in
the air that he can control and it'll
come down later and it'll explode and
you can also do a meter burn one throws
a three at once
wow that's really cool so let's say your
full screen and you have the boxing logo
you can then do the sky alert it'll
follow where the opponent is that you
can do nice here oh that's really cool
and then you can just drop it just can
you can sit there up all Darkseid's
frozen taunting him flooded them there
laters under them just so I don't know
you can hit him you want to zigzag and
then we gave them smoke arrow which is
actually a teleport Wow and you'll
instantly teleport to what the opponent
is and he could attack out it nice that
seems pretty awesome it's pretty
powerful so if you're having trouble
getting in and you're just not doing
enough damage with your arrows at any
time you can come in start your mix-ups
homes got respected alright and that
lets you start doing your Skyler so
these two are both one slot moves that
complement each other and there's many
many other type of loadouts depending on
how you like to play the game all right
awesome let's move on a little outfit
again yeah I know it's really good right
yeah let's move on who do you want to
move on to Green Lantern Hal Jordan yes
yes okay that one will be fuzzy get
really good yes hell yes yes well there
are many really there are there are